bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj prima di
cominciare il video ragazzi volevo dirvi
che siamo arrivati in questo preciso
istante a 2 milioni di iscritti ragazzi
ed io che non ho veramente parole
ragazzi grazie grazie grazie dovranno
uscire al primo dei quattro speciali per
i 2 milioni di iscritti
adesso mi concentro su questo video poi
penseremo al resto i ragazzi oggi ho
voluto fare una roba che volevo fare da
un secolo e c30 lega di google myself
consiste nel cercare il proprio nome su
google per vedere che cosa esce fuori e
dei ragazzi inizierà a vedere che cosa
esce fuori se stiamo favi j su google è
un po strano non ho mai fatto ad ragazzi
schede f a su google le prime tre cose
sono facebook fastweb
e poi c'è fa vj va bene a caso fa vj per
per gli occhi casse fuori che belle foto
che belle foto che escono belley mi
piace quando ciò sta faccia propria
famiglia inizia che ha non per i 2
milioni di iscritti
va beh siamo un po in ritardo ma mi
dicono anche gli utenti non stanno più
nella pelle io non sto più nelle palle
però parigi il re di youtube la stampa
dove sta la mia corona di preciso
scusatemi sempre desiderato essere la
principessa sis che l'uomo al
supermercato con lo skate trasgressivo
al mio i sta che anche anche il mio trek
che bella news trek
gli faccio un film figlio del web quindi
ho messo incinta la è proprio un peccato
che non esistano web preservativi primo
cercare fa vj su il segreto è vedere che
minchia esce fuori donna di 14 anni
vorrei tanto baciare pomiciare confapi
ci faccia sentire le tue mani sui miei
pettorali maschili come lo so che 10th
guardando il mio capezzolo
vabbè ragazzi la smetto perché c'è
scritto donna di 14 anni quindi potrei
passare per pedofilo tornano i 18 anni
mi piace da impazzire fa vj non ne sono
innamorata e nemmeno lo idolatra ma lo
adoro mi fa ridere un sacco e mi rilassa
mio cugino di 12 anni lo segue ha fatto
la foto con lui sono invidiosa da morire
fai benissimo ad essere invidiosa cara
perché anche io alla foto con me stesso
io e tuo fratello
abbiamo un culo così donna di 14 anni
voglio un fidanzato e siccome non ce lo
dico a tutti che sono fidanzata con fori
j fa molto piacere cara ma siccome sei
anche tu donna di 14 anni tocca amica
pezzo ho finalmente un uomo uomo di 21
anni subito dopo essermi masturbato
guarda un video di fa vj per farmi
ammosciare il pisello in fretta a non
tenere il bagno occupato per molto caro
amico ti fai ammosciare il birillo
guardando i miei video quindi deduco a
logica che tutti i masturbi pensando a
uomini belli e siccome sei un uomo di 21
anni deduco che la tua categoria sui
umedia se a quella con la y alla fine
tanti auguri ho segnato fa vj che
ammazzava tutta la mia classe mi sono
svegliata alla seconda puntata quando
mancavamo da uccidere io il mio ex
sto aspettando la terza puntata questo
post è del 4 gennaio 2015 quindi
presumibilmente è già successo
a
[ __ ] perfetto ragazzi primo cercare
fa vj su google immagini per vedere che
cosa esce fuori
ma perché ma chi è che a me ma a parma
per chi è ma chi è che mi ha fatto una
foto mentre ero sulla metro ma che i
paparazzi de merda alle 6 del mattino
uno non può prendere la metro stanco
morto che uno li fa la foto privacy nel
culo ho anche dovuto picchiare una
vecchia col bastone per prendere quel
posto guardalinee panni di re un
artificio ne fa vj caso ma come c'è
anche il video sta roba
ma che cosa palpita fa mi sono la
ragazza di 14 anni di in segreto voglio
toccare tuo capezzolo ne fa vj come gesù
che chi cazzo è che scrive restituito il
pg ha pubblicato una foto sul suo
profilo in cui si è paragonato a gesù ha
inciso si ma stavo scherzando mi chiamo
credo di essere gesù cammino sull'acqua
nuovi utenti hanno infatti modificato la
foto creando dei fotomontaggi davvero
belli non sei serio perché perché sto
invocando gesù che fasti fotomontaggi ma
per dio
ma come fa vj ragazzi l'unico uomo che
riesce a evocare il drago cerro non
consente sfere ma con due perché le
altre sono le sue palle deve essere zeus
questi sono fulmini credo che siano più
spaghetti scotti che fulmini fa vj
quanto conosci il gamer numero uno in
italia partecipa in cui partecipiamo dai
ragazzi proviamo vedere se riesco a fare
un quiz su di me ma siete sicuri di
sapere proprio tutto su fa vj ma prima
domanda come si chiamava il primo canale
youtube di falli j
il mio primo canale si chiamava lori 600
56 creato nel 2007 quindi la risposta
non è nessuna di queste tre malgrun che
fanno i quiz su di me non mi conoscono
neanche porca [ __ ] mente del gaming ma
non è sbagliato in quella data fa vj si
è iscritto a youtube ho detto prima il
mio primo canale e del 2007 quindi amici
e può essere sono tutte sbagliate dai
certo il quiz su fa vj sbagliato bravo
come si chiama la fidanzata di fa
vigenti conosco un casino di persone che
si chiamano così il problema è che
nessuna di esse e la mia fidanzata
quindi perfetto mancia inventiamo quella
donna giulia perché una giuria di
spostarla tra qual è la fobia di fa vj
la mia fobia sono questi quiz di merda
ostro fobia paura dei ragni ho paura del
buio questo è giusto paura dei ragni
quanti anni a favi dei ragazzi
io vent'anni le risposte sono 19 15 e 21
che cosa cazzo devo inserire mi metto 21
e sbagliate cazzi tuoi quel vero nome di
fa vice o dio mio lorenzo bravo grande
una bravissimo a far vincere i piace la
nutella o la patata c'è un qualcosa che
mi piace ancora di più della fatata ed è
quando la gente mette lacca del verbo
avere dove non c'è il verbo avere
completato il test quanto conosci fa vj
con un punteggio di 2,5 su 61 non sapeva
se era vero falsa quindi mi ha detto
vediamo di meta punto ma [ __ ]
questi mi conoscono meglio di quanto mi
conosca io fantastico fa vj e nuova vice
chi è morto crisi pasta la morte di
falli jake è staro oggi vi parlerò di un
mistero riguardo al nostro mito fuori
jpg e piangendo e singhiozzando si alzò
per vomitare sul pavimento dietro
l'assegno sembrava che c'era del sangue
con delle mosche su una poltrona era un
cadavere di un bambino morto ma ti
droghi zio c'è il cadavere di un bambino
morto alle mie spalle zio spiega milic e
droghe ti fai non voglio capire un
attimo il senso di questo cazzo
ma che cazzo mi è successo c'è lo
piccolo adesso sono segreti di schede ci
vediamo il posto vino bella cifra zio lo
devi prendere carlo devi prendere capito
che c'è la mano ma un capro ma
[ __ ] ragazzi concluso che il video
è stato alquanto strano cercare prove
anzi non lo farò mai più credo
preparatevi domani per lo speciale 2
milioni di iscritti che sarà il primo
dei quattro speciali ma sarà una bomba
pazzesca io spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto questo qui intendo se vi è
piaciuto ma seguito all'assalto
argomento vi piace non mi piace per i
quiz che sono da dio proprio anzi da
gesù anche la pace di facebook e come
non divido tra la tana descrizioni se
non stavo vestiti stretti amici vediamo
al prossimo è la ragazza